hello everybody and welcome to awesome
comics your one-stop shop for everything
comic book entertainment I am your host
Walter Bernays yakin today we are
covering season 1 of DC's legends of
tomorrow and our panel as usual we can
see these two here let's go with this
guy for us what's your name pal Brian
Porter Brian Porter how do you spell
there with why ok better than brain
which is the other how about you I have
I my honor and I haven't I handle I and
a bunch of this I would ask how to spell
that but don't have time all right so
I'm host Walt's maze yank and like I
said we're talking about DC's legends of
tomorrow
um as always I want to thank you guys
for commenting about what you want to
see us cover on the show always do that
keep doing that and we will look over
all that stuff and cover as much of what
you want to see as cover as possible
so keep commenting ok everybody we're
gonna get right into this so overall
pains of DC's legends of tomorrow we're
gonna start with Porter what do you
think of the show as a series in general
I liked it I thought it was good it was
fresh I liked the dynamic of the
characters you have a very wide range of
characters with personalities and powers
and you know traits and ones that
whatnot I thought it was great I really
liked this show it's not like an amazing
show or anything it's still got a lot of
room to improve but overall I enjoyed it
you know there was rarely any times
where I was like legitimately bored more
like why would you do that there was a
couple of times it was like that was
kind of stupid right but overall I like
to show I thought was a good show and
I'm excited and I'm excited for more so
ok my opinions of it like it's ok I
don't see there's no like major issues I
have of the show but it's it just didn't
come to high above mediocrity for me I
mean it's it's not terrible it's not
very good it's it's really clunky I
think is a good word to describe
everything the storytelling some of the
character relationships and just the
first season overall I think was very
trying to find its footing and it never
really found it I think maybe season 2
they will and I'm excited to see
or that stuff and yeah it's an enjoyable
for the most part we were talking about
comparing it to Supergirl and I think I
think DC's legends of tomorrow is
overall a little bit better than the
first season of Supergirl but I think
Supergirl hit higher highs and sunk to
lower lobes so you know take that how
you will but I still I'd still enticed
me enough where I want to see more of it
I just think that there's easy stuff
they could have fixed that they didn't
fix and you know as the season went
along I thought they would adjust and
they didn't but season two looks
promising so I'm excited for that
overall opinions well let's start with
like the first five minutes of episode
one which I started watching the show
when it first aired and five minutes in
we've got Arthur Darvill as a time
master
you can't trick me he's the doctor
I'm already in I'm hooked it's basically
superhero doctor okay no matter what
happens guess what I'm gonna keep
watching this show because and then also
the computer on the ship is Gideon which
tribute for you my cat's name is Gideon
how did you know that I needed the show
make it happen overall they're like I
like the show but I would I would agree
that there's plenty of room to grow I
liked being able to see these other
characters that are introduced in other
shows altogether so I'm gonna definitely
keep watching okay I think oh that is yo
okay it's freshman season so you get a
lot of stuff to work with anyway you
have a large cast with a lot of
different personalities and you need to
all of them have screen time so that's
gonna be difficult to juggle as well and
the whole show is based on time travel
which is a bitch to deal with I love
time travel let's talk about positive
first we'll get in stand in two
negatives on my mind but what were some
of your favorite stuff from season I
like to the Jonah Hex episode and you'll
agree with me on this episode but we got
Western space wait a minute are we doing
a Firefly
my keywords I liked that episode a lot I
thought that was really cool I think
costuming of the show is really awesome
I love the design
I don't really have any specific
favorite shows I just have like favorite
characters and favorite moments like
Mick and Leonard snart
you know any time they let's bring
together it's awesome right I love it I
know you guys think that like Leonard
snart could be a little over the top of
time are you sure about that corner I
don't know I'm sure that maybe he's just
a little over the top
my problem with that she was I started
watching legends of tomorrow before I
started watching a flash because I was
behind in my cue sorry unfortunate I
know so I was introduced to him at his
like top of the character where he's
like super over the top and doing all
his stuff already now that I've seen
flash it makes so much more sense and I
think I needed to work my way into that
character
so if okay obviously that's your problem
and it's not good but anyway what do you
do it I'm sure I'm sure people going
crazy now but I don't want my arrow
there anyway I like Stephen Malvo but
okay anyway positives for me I mean yeah
I also agree the Mikan and snap stuffs
the probably the strongest character
relationship on this on the show and I
wasn't always like a huge fan of start
and everything but he does grow on you
like the more you see him and stuff and
I he ended up being one of the best
characters on the show
yeah rip hunter I thought was really
cool yeah I thought everything with rip
he was I mean even if they gave him crap
sometimes I like even lines and some of
this character arc is kind of weird but
yeah I thought Arthur Darvill pulled it
off like without a doubt absolutely
he's great I'll probably watch whatever
he's in favorite episodes for me starts
to be 2046 oh you know what that was
really loved future one arm Ollie
straight out of absolutely was awesome
it was almost you know I thought that
makeup could have been done a little bit
better but he looked pretty good yeah
left behind episode where the Kendra and
my favorite episode I think I was like
alright they nailed like really good but
I think that's just because because yeah
and I agree with you about the
Magnificent episode and in the Old West
and everything rips attachment to the
the Old West too and like how he got
caught very like time displacement
whatever that was really cool I think
how his look kind of got influenced by
Jonah Hex that was his jacket or
whatever it's nice touch yeah yeah you
gotta talk to herself kinda even though
this is like her past self it's still
like her future self right so it's weird
dude I really do the absolute lips was I
thinking about it now I really did like
was the episode where they had to go
like go save their younger selves and
all that stuff from being erased from
time like I really like guys I like
seeing I seeing make interact with this
kid was just like younger so yeah that
was a good whole story arc was like
setting stuff on fire and how he felt
about it with the kid that was awesome
you know Leonard snart with the baby
just how he was dealing with that was
just common and everybody else like
young Sarah seeing what she started and
where she is like that was also
everybody's kind of annoying
get to kind of see her to do right
exactly so I like kind of having to see
them both like deal with each other
right yeah firestorms dad what's uh I
remember Jax's dad's name but yeah but
no Jax is dead that was my whole thing
was yeah really good yeah it was cool
okay let's we got a quickly move along
sorry guys negatives do you guys have
anything negative to say before I take
this over go ahead
um just the time-travel thing it's just
really hard to deal with yeah if you
wanna get to that later but is really
hard to do because well it's not real
but there's a lot of science behind it
but there's not science and so it's hard
yeah it's hard to like keep it together
keep the continuity together when you
got all this stuff going on and it's
like I think they did as good of a job
as I think they could have there could
have been other stuff better they could
have like taken from like back to the
future and you know some various other
stuff that kind of it could have Pig
mated with an employer maybe a simpler
with the timelines and stuff like that
but for the most part I think they got
it down as good as possible
sure okay my opinion on this just I
appreciate them trying something
different they're trying to branch out
to the CW universe the flare over us
whatever they're trying to make
different things I like that they tried
a new show it's cool that they had
bringing rip hunter who ever thought
we'd see a line actually in the first
place I mean that's really cool the
problem I have it with it though is like
the time-travel stuff is very nuanced
and rare and stuff in the flash series I
mean it's kind of a big deal when
somebody time travels in the flash and
they made kind of just undercut that a
little bit I think with the show because
now you make an entire show just about
time travel
I like time travel it's a great
storytelling device it like you know
it's hard to really go wrong with it but
with this I just thought I kind of
cheapened what what they built with the
flash and everything because when like I
said before when you travel through time
in the flash it's a big deal and now it
you know they're just going be nearly
everywhere there's a whole like sect of
people that are time masters that's like
what they do though it allows remedies
remember I told you
timeline to help guide them you know
berry flies blind and so and he's not he
doesn't have anybody there to guide him
like it does for everybody else when I
keep the timeline in text or whatever
Barry does something ie flashpoint you
know there's there's a big deal with
that but whether they do it it's more
controlled so I think was actually
that's another problem I had with it was
with the oculus thing so everyone's
controlled everybody has their movements
everything is just controlled by the
oculus like no sorry that's really
really lazy it was a controlling Luis I
think no they said they directly said
everything that they've ever done was
controlled by which mean they were guys
who actively things so yeah they were
controlled but it was whatever said they
said it they said in the show that
they're controlled by the oculus
everyone ever they manipulate time and
stuff so anything that they did any
decision they made was controlled by
that that's what they said so they mean
anything that's ever happened in flash
or arrow controlled by the oculus screw
off sorry I think that's really stupid
but they kind of reprimanded that when
they destroyed it which I was like yes
finally what was your thought on Chronos
closer I loved Nick coming back next mix
whole story particularly like how they
kind of just dropped it like they went
then went back to it at the end well no
because they captured him and then he's
like well I guess I'm a good guy now
like I kind of felt like that that like
they didn't really conclude it very well
like back around and then they tried
they did when they went back to the
vanishing point they tried to brainwash
him again but that's like him actually
accepting the team he's like you know
what to not be Chronos oh I don't want
to be desperate later I thought it was
really cool that it was him and then I
felt like they kind of just move on
really quickly before we go into the
next subject here how rip kind of just
know stuff and then but he's
beforehand don't match up with him
knowing something like it just you know
I knew this was gonna happen wine is
gonna happen but the why didn't you act
a certain way it didn't match up I think
with character motivations and things
like that the the shoehorn romance I
think of Ray and Kendra I think I I
really got into it as it went along but
how it started was really like out of
nowhere
I mean Carter like just died and then
Jax is like I really really like Kendra
man hey man I love Kendra and then
freakin ray just steps in and then they
have a relationship that just like I
said comes out of nowhere that's why I
really liked the episode with her stuck
in the 50s because it builds up their
whole relationship and everything when
they come out of it it's believable and
I was rooting for them from then on you
know I mean but I thought you were my
name was kind of lame like specifically
because they bring up the fact that time
travel is sort of like luxury for white
guys time trouble because any point in
time anywhere you're good then you might
not be so great you have to be selective
of where you go yeah that's that was I
liked that little nod the rational
nitpick I had was the thing with Sarah
and snart just like why they make out
she gave him a you're about to die screw
it I'm gonna kiss you kiss they were
kind of like they built that up in like
two episodes
I thought someone's gonna be the ripping
Sarah I thought that was there was
something happening there yeah I mean I
just thought there was another thing
that kind of stuck out but okay really
quickly besides the Nick and snart stuff
there's any other characters you guys
really liked like any arcs or
performances it's Vandal Savage
you like Sam great I mean all the stuff
that I've seen Savage
in comics and you know animated stuff
like this was an awesome on-screen
representation of sandwich you know I
think that I mean yeah they had to
change his origin some but yeah Mike was
forgiving that he just was awesome he
was a badass character I think he had a
lot to him I liked him a lot
anything else no I pretty much talked
about the characters yeah I did really
like I liked all of the characters okay
I liked all the characters every
character had a good point for me but
you know some of them were better than
the others one thing that I really did
like that's not a character and last
episode I loved the thanagarian tie-ins
yeah that was awesome because I was like
oh come on I wanted to see actual
thanagarians
I mean I want to be that way instead of
like you know prince khufu and all that
but it's like Aryans were coming I was
like okay I'm on board with this that's
awesome
hey everyone beth-el Durkin with awesome
comics and I'm in a little neighborhood
called Andersonville to check out one of
the best-kept secret comic book shops in
all of Chicago so secret in fact you
might not even know it exists but it
does and it's right here let's go in oh
my god it's so secret like I have to
walk all the way back here to figure it
out it's like Diagon Alley it's so
mysterious do you think Hagrid's gonna
show up and tell me I might be a witch
or a wizard
all right so I am here with Saleem
idelle co-owner of alley cat comics so
slain how long have you guys been here
in Andersonville we've been here for
five years what made you guys first
decide to open up the comic book shop
cuz you and your husband right it is we
had too many comics and I told him he
needed to either open up a shop or get
rid of them and so we opened up a shop
so tell me a little bit about your
influence on the selection in the comic
book job because obviously comic book
shops are going to reflect what the
owners preferences are in personality so
what kind of prints have you put on le
cat I think that my particular
preferences are Indy books I tend to
read more Indy books and I keep up on
them so I'm kind of a bolito Nick when
he does the ordering you know you should
get this book this looks really cool
this writer was really great on this
book you should check out this one so
that's kind of where I come into play
with all that stuff what do you love
about comics I love that they are
amazing stories that you can read if
you're enjoying television right now you
have to come read comic books because I
feel like that I mean it's clear that
they're using comic books or movies for
scripts and stuff like that and if the
movies are great just imagine how it was
originally
what's one comic book here that has not
been made into a movie that you think
absolutely must probably saga would be
amazing if that were a movie I don't
know if they could do it justice though
but if they did
I'm thinking like an HBO Game of Thrones
style thing in order to really get it
across if they put the money behind it
oh my god
saga yes arts lien so as you know
legends of tomorrow just wrapped up its
first season boy what are your thoughts
well I honestly haven't seen the last
episode but I was talking about this
with Nick last night and we were talking
about how CW shows sometimes feel a
little kitschy or campy and he named off
a couple and one of them was
supernatural I mean and I was like that
show was great and I go wait no you know
what the first season wasn't that great
and you can actually fast-forward to the
very last episode of that season and
know exactly what happened so I kind of
feel like that may be what's going on
with this particular show I'm gonna give
it another chance I'm gonna keep going
cuz who knows it could surprise us all
all right well thanks so much everyone
for joining us on awesome comics all
right thanks a lot Beth okay everybody
so are we excited for season 2 there's a
little okay spoilers I shouldn't mention
at the beginning spoilers for what's
coming here at the end of the final
episode we see Rex Tyler aka our man
show up out of nowhere and mention the
Justice Society of America how excited
you guys was using too excited I think
there's plenty of room to see some other
characters you know or other characters
that maybe if you're I'm not watching
the show I'm just reading the comics I
think there's room for new characters
I'm holding out for Booster Gold maybe
maybe maybe a blue B it all probably
won't happen but like there's times with
rip hunter and I think that'd be really
cool if we could get some of that maybe
not season two maybe if it keeps going
but I think there's plenty of room to go
some we'll see alright yeah I'm I'm
really excited for the JSA you know I
think that's a really awesome way to go
and you know the hour man that's gonna
be really cool yeah I think that's good
you know we can get some obscure
characters we get yeah good characters
coming in like would love to see Booster
Gold wasn't them dr. fate the part of
the joy yeah I mean there's a ton of
characters that we could totally have
dr. Lee it would be really cool like
there's a lot of stuff that they could
do a lot of avenues that they can go
to see what they do some I'm on board
I'm right with you guys there I mean I
like I said I didn't love the first
season but I think there is room to
improve and I like the characters enough
where I'm interested to see where it
goes
okay final thoughts I am I like it I'm
gonna see season two oh man
same I'm ready for more you know I want
some more I want some more different
characters you know I want I want some
obscure characters some bigger
characters let's go all out season two I
agree we get a full season there's only
16 episodes yeah weird for the first
season so hopefully we get a four season
I get 22 or whatever the average is okay
I'll pick it week we have a special one
so I'm gonna take it away legends it
smart this series came out this year
this is just the first book if you want
to go check it out I I'm personally not
super invested in these characters
actually I read it and I was kind of
excited to like see what's going on
we've got firestorm obviously like in
the show but other than that it's it's
not really a parallel to the show much
is anyone else reading this do you
disagree with me um yeah oh I'll read
the other couple there's three out right
now and there should be more so you know
what you think of the series if you're
reading it um otherwise go check it out
let me know what you think other than
that I do definitely want to give a
shout out to Jean ha whose first issue
of May just got released this month go
check it out through Dark Horse Comics
and for my birthday present look he's
back in the cowl and then amazing so go
check out it's beautiful you've got some
doctor who references he's got some
Avatar The Last Airbender stuff in there
um so this is a series I'm super excited
about it's gorgeous so definitely
definitely go check him out and he's a
local guy to us so chicken up all right
cool boy where can we find on the social
medias of facebook.com slash awesome
Porter you right here oh my goodness
it's me Facebook Twitter Instagram don't
work anywhere Oh
all right you can find me on Twitter at
awesome underscore Walter and I'll be
talking about all this kind of stuff all
the time so any cams like movie news I
like to discuss it with you guys so make
sure you go on and follow me and all
these guys on Twitter and Facebook and
everything okay so what we got coming up
next actually later this week we're
gonna come come out with a bonus episode
for season three of Marvel's agents of
shield it wanted to cover that as well
because that season also wrapped up this
past week so we'll be talking about that
later this week so stay tuned for that
next week we will be talking about
season two of the flash and we will also
be talking about x-men apocalypse of
course this is coming out so guys stay
tuned for that and until later this week
I guess we'll see you on the next stage